kamil there are rumors there are reports
you selected the uber poor washing over
what ladies I love this pairing so much
oh thank you yeah and Camille you've
done a lot of comedy Dave I would say
too because of Guardian but how was it
kind of leading your first comedy
basically there was some it was
stressful I was nervous about it was
like it's just it's not a comfortable
place for me Oh something was something
that was foreign to me I didn't I wasn't
super confident about it but I was you
know very open-minded I am kind of in
general I'm open mind I'm okay with
being a student but it is it's getting
out of my comfort zone a little bit it
was great I liked seeing you and Karen
kind of teaming up what was that like
doing out of bat makeup kind of
different Carol
it was so great because I love her she's
like one of my favorite people but
actually we were on a press junket here
for Avengers infinity war when I found
out that she was gonna be my partner and
Stuber we were crossing each other and
the elephant elevator wasn't past and
she said hey I'm done a movie with you
next month and I said which one she said
still harassing no way but it was really
great to just be there and be out of
makeup and just be able to be ourselves
the Karen she's just one of my she's
such a sweet person like she's a
pleasant woman that I love yeah she's
awesome she really did speaking of
Guardians three James Gunn is back yeah
so excited but I got asked because there
was like you were like fully prepared to
jump ship maybe go do Suicide Squad was
that like a real thing that was in the
works no no it wasn't that I was gonna
jump shoot ship and do Suicide Squad I
was more at the point where I was like
fire me I don't care you're gonna hear
what I have to say this is the way I
feel and this is I think you made a bad
call and I don't care if you fire me
because I feel this way this is me being
honest and me sticking up for my friend
who was wronged so that was it wasn't
about me you know I'm not threatening to
go to do Suicide Squad I was just
saying I things are right here I'm just
gonna leave I don't want to be a part of
this yeah so how are you feeling now
that he's back now I feel great and I
think uh you know it's weird it almost
feels a statement that they actually
came back they came back they admit that
they just made a wrong decision like or
something you know for a huge juggernaut
of a corporation like Disney to say we
made a mistake and we're gonna you know
we're gonna make this run all right I
mean that says something you don't have
anything if they can do that if they can
change their mind say they made mistaken
anybody can you know sometimes it's
never too late to say you were wrong
Camille there are rumors what everybody
was I'm sure I I can't talk well very
excited about the rumor I love Marvel
you know I mean it would be a dream to
be in one of those movies
[Applause]
[Music]